so full podcast with Felipe Esparza and
Rosie go Torres yeah man welcome to
another episode of the what's a food
podcast live here and on all things
comedy on your audience Comedy Network
or iTunes audio boom SoundCloud or
wherever you may find this podcast also
everybody who listens we appreciate it
if this week and farm you get to write a
good review about the podcast on iTunes
that way we can find out who's listening
and it also helps with our ratings Aaron
farm
we got like 50,000 listeners so if only
like 10% of you guys could leave a
comment that'll be at some 5,000 okay
maybe 10% of that can leave a comment
that's 500 people how about this just a
hundred of you guys leave a comment keep
it 100
keep it 100 you know how you do go to
iTunes subscribe
we don't have iTunes or anywhere even if
you're tweeting just say I'm keeping it
100 this show keeps a 100 so if a
hundred of you guys leave a comment or a
review you know push our ratings and
we'll get more advertisers and this week
were in no where were you in where this
week this weekend just be creeping
around okay he'll be creeping around so
look out for him creeping around with
you lady
they'll be creeping around with
Rodrigo's lady rocks town right yeah and
her son Rodrigo doesn't know it but it's
like an instant father already you have
to raise a kid
it's where when you raise the kid when
when you did a woman that has a kid is
like you really want to like them or
[ __ ] at all you don't have no choice
because you gotta like her
but um I was trip out when like I'm
dating somebody and they asked me if it
was all right if I bring my kid I'm like
do you know I live in a studio right
Allu I had a studio and a girl want to
bring her son and they spend the night I
mean I had a studio and I had our
Rodrigo in the kitchen with Vinny and me
and my lady in her certain other bedroom
with my other son yeah so one time they
were kind of a Halloween eating pizza
Jack Leonard how many cheese pizza in a
long time you miss that [ __ ] yeah
keeping it 100 I miss the saltiness and
the gooey of it forget about it and with
a sauce man but what I think about it
now I know I'm gonna really I know not
not knowing not knowing it now knowing
how Jesus made you know and like you
have to like you know when you when you
pour milk like real milk like cow milk
straight from the tea yeah I've had it
like that it makes me wrong it's wrong
it's like to the chase nothing like the
milk that cover the galley huh no that's
just processed it yeah but the milk that
comes out of the cow like when you get
another cow it's sweet
oh yeah it dick I would like buttery
well it has that little cream on the top
that's what I mean okay I took apart the
cream on top that's where they say it's
the cream of the taco that's like the
best party my which rises to the top the
cream and we let it rise that becomes
butter if you churn it right yeah or um
cheese did you let it stay there becomes
cheese just a little bit of salt did you
know that um that um I'm not saying like
Swiss cheese but some cheese's you know
they put a little animal inside and it
sick so he could like go through you
know go inside the the cheese to make
the hose oh okay that's how they make
that Swiss though the holes in the Swiss
yeah what's happening guys
no you know they make head cheese
I don't want to know all right hey hey
you know I got who I got you bro yeah
dawg hey dude you know what I was funny
you're talking about when you're raising
a kid or have a lady with a kid already
you know who was thinking about the
other day
remember what Vinnie used to get mad
when you used to call him that what
remember gravy fool Grady the little kid
named Grady people used to call Vinnie
Grady's remember that kid named Grady
you know all right Tyra McGrady when I
first met you dawg
he used to be sitting in the Accord in
the back dog Grady no man in Arizona now
in Arizona now remind me back first met
you dog that was the first O'Brady I was
it was Brady yes that was my first kid
broke my first drive made with a kid
yeah or they brought him along I
remember like was that I put that I put
that for top of a tree
and I started talked about for the next
two summers did you always say the
greatest trick is to take those foods
that does Disneyland so let me go back
to the other day yeah brah man that was
a scenic mountain see a lot of guys they
like a lot a lot of men I got men are
insecure you know because especially
young ones like I say like 17 to 24 then
I was I thought your most insecure as a
man gets between his 20 and 24 very
insecure hating on everything
hey Leon is on a successful friends just
Haiti bro at very unsecure
like if he dates a girl with a girl a
girl with a baby
he hates the baby daddy without even
meeting them oh I was not even mediate
um bro
he wants to kill him already anger
issues angry bro not me I've been
opposite bro like I remember mice dating
somebody and like
Brady and he called he told his um his
sir
you know fat well I am fat then then he
wouldn't go to my dad said you were fat
really really food
I give that food piggyback rides all day
go by the whole ice cream okay he was
something he got it hey he might be
family strong I took him everywhere bro
because I want him to go back to his
father and talk about how much of a good
time we had
and he did Oh dad you know Felipe to me
he put on top of a tree a tree now that
for hates trees
oh yeah become a lumberjack that's how
you do it man you don't go there to kill
mother [ __ ] just because you're dating
somebody's baby mama sometimes our baby
the real guy gets jealous
well he's trying to move in on my son
let me take him off oh God
ain't nobody trying to move into my son
which is a move out of our son
I just left somebody with a son you
didn't want to pick up your [ __ ]
cross later son I know my thing I want
to pick this guy up yeah we for sweet
hell now I see him everyday cuz you know
I'm gonna be with a mom every day was a
baby nursing the baby mama gets mad - oh
man is even worse
[ __ ] hate new baby mama oh dude
especially like your bum see man I
remember man if you were the best way
for a baby mama like just stay like um I
like women get jealous they are why is
it way that woman holding my baby who
the [ __ ] gonna hold your baby in that
around [ __ ] but later for the floor put
him on a tree
oh they get you know I mean how come
that baby I'll call that good baby best
Rest really my son you know what your
son's 12 you like I know member back in
the days dude if you were a poor woman
with with um with kids she the Kings
will hire you to breath be the but the
baby
yeah the Prince of when the Queen never
breastfed dog all those titties never
bro she's just gonna it oh yeah you see
that white woman around with that dirty
one
wash your titties and let that
breastfeed the little
who said what he's done for reals bro
like everybody watches Game of Thrones
and I never watched that show bro
I watched that show my fall asleep you
mentioned a dragon's coming I'm gonna
fall asleep I'm not down for the Wizards
bro I see enough white people in real
life you know running [ __ ] I don't want
to see him running [ __ ] medieval times
t2
coming watch over when white people were
running [ __ ] so we get to that movie
yeah planning the Apes but then again
you want Player of the Apes and the
light-skinned a plat Aves on the smaller
ones and the gorillas are security
guards for reals man like a color thing
anyways man lost my point
oh yeah Game of Thrones right everybody
watching Game of Thrones in them oh man
he's chicks are [ __ ] hot let me tell
you man how dirty and stinky more for
the world back then this guy just came
from battling seven wars several waters
you know the food never changed only
where a lot of food lost and battle
because they were [ __ ] rosado bro
musty I bet everybody there stuck
between the legs
dog they were saying she brought two
dragons I don't teach about dragon
teaching but her legs were opening match
her dragon breath yeah Mac you know
people were stinky back there fo
spreading he was having a good old day
well before you all ran
toothbrushes yeah mess we were at the
brain improv all week eight shows seven
shows sold out a lot of food showed up
MC Pancho showed up with Charlie
la Chamba Rita anniversary date
anniversary date bro how how long can
you spend it without comment with if you
don't have comedy right and then Sunday
night
[ __ ] what's the name showed up
crazy Ruben from Instagram follow crazy
Ruben MC Pancho to crazy Ruben he's this
guy that he's tattooed from his toes all
the way to his head tattoo even his
[ __ ] palm was have tattoos here that
the two of her home eat on his arm who
has a tattoo therefore good party
hell yeah he can definitely party that
fool didn't want it to end he won't go
to sleep on you he would not go to sleep
on him I'll put it sure if I was single
and not sober me and this guy with a
putter took off for three nights
straight tango & cash hell yeah bro who
took the uber bro oh he did for some
reason I thought he came in on a
motorcycle done he was all pissed off
well kind of like bummer I'm bummed
because I'm when he got to the club you
know man oh this little white lady drove
me to the tabria first thing I come into
the she says to me when I get into the
car hey are you going to a Halloween
party it's knocked over lady like his
whole face is tattoo done yeah we were
seen out then a movie with Jay Hernandez
we place that cholo in a Marvel movie or
Suicide Squad Suicide Squad what this
guy his face is more tattoo than that
yeah man yeah man this guy's the current
guy then I'm gonna look for he's never
go to no job or any of your try to get a
bank loan for real this food goes he's
been everywhere bro I guess when you're
all tattooed it out people want to hang
out with you I seen him with photos with
him and um Rihanna
yeah dude he said that he partied with
Justin Bieber
he said Justin Bieber does every type of
drug I believe it did more either rehab
now the Beeb is in rehab yeah man when
your yo you could do a lot of drugs bro
push SuperDuper long-ass line bro but I
have a heart attack you do when you're
old to [ __ ]
because there's no fool to do drugs
forever and then they stop doing drugs
and they die down
I see what observes your ass keep our
young ass fool do drugs and it trying to
invite me like one little bump in [ __ ] I
think younger let me have a dog that's
what I'm saying
a little spoon oh man like that one do
it man we were and um in Milwaukee that
forgive me that psycho weed and I look a
little stack of powder see how Pierre
that she was it's it's more like I
always think that if it smells like I
don't know what what Pierre spot you'll
smell ya know unless you try it baby
Holy Smoke Pierre PC
what is pc pc like a 20 elephant record
neither joy was invented in the Pico
Guardians housing projects Kim is there
huh yeah the world's broke my
neighborhood saw the most before crack
was there nothing but PCP bro like they
need to call it though I don't know
member everybody there so PCP man they
have gallons of that [ __ ] fools
I seen more digs than I can tell you bro
for fools taking their clothes off
dude uh you have you done nation before
yeah but they won't see my clothes off
oh yeah how's that [ __ ] make you feel
well I got punched by the polio through
what bro I just came from a half of a
[ __ ] house party right house party or
a grocery nine there's a kickback
e-everybody but when you look the
president I grew up in those foods like
like they keep me having the same person
at [ __ ] outbreak that staring at the
pinata is the gathers selling your PCP
the same party many trades proof so I
never don't PC people they had it there
for free so however I found the bag of
candies where they were at and I took a
bunch of I'm gonna put him home it's
inside of my back in my pocket no
wearing overalls and a Pendleton but
yeah member I look I didn't address it
right dog because I had to pay no I
tucked in the Pendleton
so that my overruns were over the
pendant just like a farmer bro so put
all the cat
I don't like [ __ ] our Leatherface bro
from chainsaw
so I [ __ ] up dude I took the PCP
right it was dipped in a new port that's
what is supposed to do it had to be a
menthol cigarette and the guy lady oh
that's who like for puffs you know that
was it yeah that was the it bro that I
took like five steps and I threw up all
the beauty I bro lately they cook to go
to a little girl rather happy Lea with
cilantro let's go meet with cilantro and
lemon and
tortillas beans and rice and I just
walked over there and threw everything
up bro the body wasn't happy yeah and
back then I was a dirty ass probably
know about brushing your teeth right
there
I just rinsed my mouth with a water hose
on a funnel yard and gargle and then
Bohemians couldn't laugh for birthday
cake dog I was I was like it's like a
zombie bro like there must have been
like five kids there at the party but to
me was like a 2001 bro they're all
running around and I was like in a daze
and then I don't know program uh I think
I don't know what happened when
everybody took off I guess to do karaoke
in the house or go play tag and I was
the last one in the kitchen still bro
and then the owner of the guy said I'm
what are you doing my you hungry and he
said that what he said I was either
beauty I with my hammer he said I just
put in my hair and set apart for eating
it like a walker bro you're a SAP and I
heard like oh and it was cold dawg so
although [ __ ] my take on coming down
my neck is [ __ ] and they sit in the guy
just like he slapped my hair like a
little boy and they just somebody gave
me a back keep me right back to the
projects brother and then he let me in
the front seat over the back of the
trailer bro the back let's touch the bed
was in the back only the bad dog on this
rug in the freeways take me back to bed
Rocky and it just dropped me off wrong
drop me off and the police put stopped
me like like 20 minutes later like what
you were walking back to yeah I was
arguing with a light post now I was
pressing a party forever dog and not
crossing the street then the police
officers they get pulled over and [ __ ]
they held me up and then he said damn
man you got more [ __ ] candy than I
have [ __ ] bullets cuz you know I had
just given a birthday party how those
candies in my pocket it was star brownie
mini Oh bro you know that when you have
a dream and you say [ __ ] that man I've
been waking with this money in your
pocket coming apart
the see you start stuffing your pockets
and you wake up you have no money so I
was doing that when I was out PCP
doubting
so I stuffed my pocket full of [ __ ]
candy and human pinata man and when I
get to the project I'm pleased it's
[ __ ] stopping me LAPD black and white
you look nice my life you spun a PCP and
I win let's go to come Shh
Oslo brulee good - in my head it's not
like when you write a letter right and
then you write PS PostScript right so
the collar be nerdy well all right to be
a dick right but I wasn't like arguing
with him you know cuz I know a few if I
were to miss anybody would like hit mile
a little swoop for me to fall down and
all the time so I like I just hold on to
the pole the whole time you know what he
was talking to me and then um I told him
that that um so he went through my cards
and I had a card from a sergeant bro an
investigator like a CSI Harlem back
division I guess it was our sergeant
forstman I just know that right and then
the cop goes sort of well you have this
sergeant enforcement's card in your
pocket that I wanted that I get dog but
it was like a further sheesh saliva and
and boom from my mouth coming through my
finger like a 3d which
working in a case that's it we're
working on a case right now right now
the beginning stages and he named it go
dog probably his boss he thought I was a
confidential informant brother a CI who
fooled our food dog BCP doubt but see I
got that card earlier like a two weeks
ago cuz I'm they had shot somebody in
Pico ELISA and I was over there too and
um and I remember that uh somebody told
the police that I was there that was
that um I don't know I was always I was
always there after everything happened
so when the police are taking names I
always take my name today Felipe Esparza
man I live over there and 145 Clarence
Street if you need more information but
but I'm mostly like I forget that I did
these things give my information around
so the police come back to my house then
it's a police or who I was doing so many
bad [ __ ] back then that I yeah I forgot
that I give him my number
so I ran uh I [ __ ] around fool I took
off so they now the next day they came
back again and I try to go to the back
door again they're waiting for me ah
maybe hang comes me inside a house and I
haven't done nothing you know doc Dean I
just came by [ __ ] no neighborhood
name down for more information you know
about that shooting but I know nothing
so they took me back to the police
station and they asked me out why'd she
took off the first time
I don't know I don't know scared [ __ ]
scared
I thought you gonna take me for
something I don't know man just oh just
scared
then he that's when I'm that guy gave me
the card wall if you know anything about
the car that shot that kid give us a
call so I just kept the car bro so it
was my fish card
canary signature on it it was the legit
so when I gave to the cop bro
it was like he looked at her like you a
monopoly bro like get a jail free card
fool all mad dogs um because I'm I came
rushing on bro but I was like the last
one one of the last time that their PC
peek another time I got jumped by 17
dudes goddamn and they hit me with a
pole and I still stood up bro
PCP is good I choose you that you
Incredible Hulk
accept that you like Wolverine bro you
look except that you but you throw the
pain like two hours later so you're not
really cured yeah man we're so full
podcast with Rodrigo Torres right here
looking like Bob's Big Boy we're doing
it roll okay man yeah before we get to
our guest we got a couple of shoutouts
here man put on my glasses off woman to
acting class yesterday my my acting
class teacher said I'm go do you do you
do you work on Jax I said no I work on
that you see me wear any glasses she
goes you work ghost you should get
contract to read you know when you go to
our dish and you go where the contacts
and I said now I try that man I said I
wanted a contact just for one eye you
know so I got caught in just for one eye
just to read and the rest of the I'm
blind
come on bro all right fool upcoming
shows September 7 through 10 a bit
Orlando Florida at the Orlando improv
September 15 and 16 San Jose California
at the San Jose improv to show Saturday
three shows Sunday September 3 show
Saturday no Sunday show Friday and
Saturday that's it
September 21st through 24th Houston
Texas I don't know man that might be
canceled because you know there's a lot
of water weather right now it is flooded
over it always floods over there though
right yeah I guess this time for real
for real
that was funny man when they asked the
president you know he was on his way to
a meeting
you are anything for Texas good luck
when there's not just good luck to
everyone good luck
but people took it in a bad way but you
know you know he left out I wish
everybody good luck hang in there hang
in there stay strong fast fool I saw a
dog run away from the flood carrying dog
food bro
that's a tight ass dog they say though
the first lunar bro yes for sight he
said follow my lead clean up our and
funny man how everybody's showing like
Adam we'll be rescued man then the
bridge to you hard man when you see a
candle and a does on top of the trash
cans bro thirsty alive bro my god you
know you know my wrath took off a long
time ago haha do those rats Oh survived
in the rust which they were to upper
growl the rats are gone and they're
chilling on the attendance right now
hell yeah magical rats are [ __ ] smart
broad dude they'll be creeping over the
liars there was a [ __ ] there was
another flood somewhere else right and
they saw that the lambs the sheep we're
going to hire around higher ground right
guess who jumped on their backs rabbits
a bunch of rabbits jump on top of sheep
and they [ __ ] rode on [ __ ]
all the way to the mouse's dog and then
the guy that armed they saw that he let
the rabbits live could they have
resilience
yeah man Hart a lot of people are like
are we fighting for their FEMA checks
man and a lot of people who aren't even
evolving or [ __ ] floods punches I got
me a good idea just to get some FEMA bro
a lot of scams opening up bro dude just
wait the [ __ ] we're gonna hear about dog
and a lot lies two brothers living there
like they opened up the levees to
protect the rich people bro come on man
are you gonna protect somebody's house
or your apartment come on do the math
totally you own an apartment man you
have no rights don't forget that and if
you do have rights you don't even know
about it like nobody
I know ever gets rental insurance except
hipsters right right
they've been living in the same
apartment in Boyle Heights their whole
lives that [ __ ] burned they won't so a
nice apartment yeah man so what's our
full shoutouts to this food right here
who get our man shoutouts - um - Nando
Nando tierod Oh the at the cooked
chicken cook kitchen podcast listener
who cooks for the vegan priest and
evangelist he brought up some delicious
vegan chocolate chip cookies how are
they good and the slifers Derek and Ari
for showing up in brayer like always
louis xiii mile shoutout
anybody there spoken Louie the 13 his
mom showed up to my show she showed up
man it was tight and what else
Paul Rodriguez supposed to call it in
ten minutes but promoted new play with
I'm with Mike Gomez
you know Mike Gomez I know I know I
don't gotta know Mike Gomez Mike Gomez
is probably the coolest dude you ever
seen Big Lebowski oh yeah he's the cop
Rosie that actually reads yeah we just
hired I just touched you the crime lab
they heard two more detectives on this
case the girl working in shifts leads
Mike Gomez dog forward to a party one
time and it was letter left you know
actor PG images almost fluffy all these
fools I saw that full from big the buzz
he by himself
I said dog you got leads and then
everybody came around bro he didn't know
how popular he was and now he goes to
the Big Lebowski Fest oh yeah is that
the deal were you a column slipping
after Latino life a scam and ten grown
men all upon him bro like they got a
working in sheriff's yeah man so that's
the body a dog what's this one here east
of the river collective we got the guys
here oh yeah man were so fool what's
your name man miss Carlito hell yeah
their fire mass might right yeah yeah
this is a homing right here my lord
meaning me Mad Max was something Mad Max
was so fool our guest right now are
they're gonna be at UM at that concert
right now pay dues to pay dues man
because you know what these kids have
been paying their dues I've been hurting
about miss Carlito and this guy from
your other cousin or your nephew your
uncle or his name like Rudy Rudy Rudy
I'm ready to bring him bro he's not in
here we take a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
Facebook yeah anyways that man we all
grew up together I'm saying this in
order love because I grew up with miss
Carlitos I'm her proxy - so so good
blows - hurry man people don't know cuz
man if you choose me man people say I
didn't mind a battle but they never
mention what side was my better worried
about pocket down center really pop or
you let minor battle close to commerce
cuz you know close to harbors my you in
the hood you're in the hood [ __ ] man
that's definitely living a minor battle
with the first [ __ ] steady living
it's all glass pipes to you in a glass
prior to everybody uh it's a little rose
over there he lives in commerce man I
didn't know Commerce had a neighborhood
I thought it was just a casino and
Stephen Steakhouse know but there's like
um there's actually a residence in back
of Stephen Statehouse yeah man which it
takes them an hour to get out of their
house five o'clock the freeway [ __ ]
right there are jammed
don't forget the outlet you know there's
outlets
oh man um that's that's something like
that that's a Black Friday there last
for two months she grew up in um in
commerce that little area is that
controlled by the sheriff's or Commerce
police or LAPD
you see like public safety which is just
commerce but then you do see the
sheriff's just strolling by from time to
time just coming through neighborhoods
checking that see if everything is good
you know you guys started off together I
know you turned out so low right yeah I
used to I remember we sent you a video
[ __ ] I want to say like six years ago
maybe six seven years ago I sent you a
video with me and my other little homie
Jay Jay rapping like by right now his
name was uh
LJ LJ LJ LJ and mine and it was
mescaline or maybe Mickey I don't know
but I remember you wrote back you're
like this one's actually pretty good
sent you an earlier one that [ __ ] was
whack and you're like you told my uncle
Rudi you're like wow send me when the
[ __ ] gets good that was like six seven
years back man is crazy like full circle
for us to be on paid dues and to be
reppin Boyle Heights like it's a trip
man you you become just connected with
Boyle Heights and like I've seen myself
kind of get up there and now with all
this [ __ ] going on the gentrification
and all the unusual stuff that Boyle
Heights is in the headlines for it's
just it's a trip so um you grew up in
the projects tool you grew up away from
it
my mom grew up in the project Sylvia
Sylvia yes right whoo I know your hope I
know there's family I know um patty
right yeah that's my mom sister that's
my Hattie and then there's little Jackie
yeah and then there's one more no one
more sister another one I never met no
no that's just my mom yeah sauce made up
then then you have your um your cousin
Rudy and Louie Louie but for the big
rate of fat though oh yeah carbo I mean
if anybody have a [ __ ] Raiders
podcast it should be Louie
so know if you're out there bro little
out Davis that's what he calls himself
[Laughter]
and you knew my uncle rofl yeah man but
though folk grow their food we grew up
together but they took all that for I'm
stoner rock stoner stoner Rob or stone
or something because
heat you're hanging around without his
toner but he's into no drugs at first he
just looked like a STONER yeah bro
knocking he to ditch with them he like
curly long hair and a fool him and I
were kicking a broad pick it tough
kick it tough he saved my life
really yeah bro I was um I was standing
outside in a corner you know 5:00 in the
morning
need to call me back man back then and I
was doing bad I was doing being a
project kid you know not sleeping you
know 22 years old 21 years 20 years old
I was hanging around I'm Clarence Street
and right in front of Clement Street it
was like a meat company and then the
project and Tyson noticed I was just
slinging dope for his uncle right cuz
yeah here give a little work also really
like you know and I was are in between
slanging for money or slang and just to
smoke it myself a free so but I had out
here just gave it to me and I'm gonna go
serve these fools and they wanted like
60 so on the way there I was already
cutting that [ __ ] in half bro giving
them 30 right well it's a cup of Game
Boy 5:00 in the morning come on you
didn't get a full price its retail
wholesale prices is when the big dogs
come in by that time I'm a sleepy bro I
don't [ __ ] around with their business so
food this food pulls out a gun and he
takes it out and it goes Cuban he he
they had to say give it to me man I know
when a gun comes out and means give it
to me right so I just started giving him
money and I dropped the dope on the
floor cuz maybe if he picks it up I'll
give him a kick in the face or maybe you
know but but he picked it up pointing
the gun up so he's smart so it's not his
first rodeo so when they're leaving his
uncle comes out and I said so
his uncle comes out and then and then um
the other food comes out to the guy
named Lupe they took our Amato and why
they come here that bro name Junie
whatever there are cool people we all
grow together man
who comes out and it's a blast you know
fools dog the car everything man they
get away with our Shinto but they got
blasted on down but it was my fault you
know I could've just gave him you know
what above the post to give them you
know and got on our merry way but I'm
over here man I know try to make an
extra $30 in 10 seconds walk so he's
[Laughter]
[ __ ] after high school so I mean I
got a lot of love for the community and
I mean I really feel like I'm a part of
it now the movement and everything that
mess Carlito's kind of help build
towards and for like I don't know if his
mics on this closer you hear no I don't
hear you well you hear me right I heard
everything but I wonder it did record
right to win for Paul Rodriguez to call
so so you story in high school too
little after like it's funny cuz I I
used to tell my field Oh fees I wanted
to rap and he'd be like alright go rap
then because I was just you know kind of
just smoke weed and just write my little
Rhymes and [ __ ] in my and being my
headphones kind of shot and my field doe
fees before he passed away r.i.p here's
the one who really pushed me like dude
go out there cold spit your [ __ ] in it
up but I started a little late I would
write little rhymes
in high school but there's not likely
there wasn't a huge hip-hop like
movement in Boyle Heights when I was in
high school I don't think there's ever
really been until around now like some
of the dudes that when I first started
that put me on the older heads they were
kind of telling that same story like hey
you know whose have come up on this side
but no one's ever really put it down you
know certain stuff or if it has been
like Chicano Chicana radroach or a bro
gangbang me yeah so that's not my [ __ ]
either so we've kind of just been on
that journey ever since man I've been
like rapping out for like ten years so
is that a choice that either left you
know rapper you know trying to keep it
real in Boyle Heights is that it that's
something like you decide run away or I
don't wanna be a Chicano rapper or a
hardcore cholo Chicano rapper or just
something you just you just float into
your you get came into your own and you
decided this is the way I do it I really
like that yeah I mean you just grew into
your own self right I mean foods who try
to fake the funk like that where they
know like if they say they're hardcore
like you got story beer you could you
could have been you could have went
either way straight up because anybody
could keep gonna kept the real with
which you Carnot hardcore rap it would
be you - all right
that's the trip because some of the
foods I rap about the [ __ ] or even the
blocks they're rapping about I literally
live on those blocks and walk that [ __ ]
and I'm like fool you ain't there like
how are you gonna say that like
literally you aren't there I live right
there even La Puente wasn't even up with
the hills yeah doctor one name that's
cool with everybody so you can deny it
yeah man man I stroll with Fabian Doria
all right never never welcome to favor
and go do you know them work for it
right everyone has to make that choice
when you come from kind of the area I
see other cats maybe some foods probably
only wrapped that way because they only
saw that Lane so I'm talented dudes we
could write music and rice
they were Charlie too scared to just be
themselves or [ __ ] make a pop hit
make a hip-hop New York style [ __ ] like
you don't have to make Chicano Chicana
rap unless you want to there's some
fools who live that live and I met them
too you know like
but you kind of meet them both along the
way I know when I thought it when I when
I got it when I started when I got into
you I started like follow starting okay
miss Carlito I'm Boyle Heights I see
what up who all is out there you know
and start like listening to like um that
fool Capone right
Capone write his name Capponi Capponi
and then like um some other little
skinny food robbed little robbed then
some other foods that matter there's
some hardcore food like you can't really
share this talk it's all gang-related
yeah a million views on in San Jose but
who has been you like you're like you
know along the way you meet people that
help you who has been like very I'm
helpful to you guys or motivating you
guys and show you the robes the business
there's there's a lot of them I could
say early on like I was telling you um
one of the early people who helped us or
me personally was me soul tribe which is
Fabian de Bourgh yes no Spade yes I'm
his brother Dario Dario they were just
older cats who just I came up in the mix
as a young [ __ ] greenhorn not knowing
[ __ ] just ambitious and it kind of
showed me the ropes and other people
within that crew so they kind of I've
been she's kind of doing that for other
cats like just hooking foods are
especially further from the area man I
swear you just say it from Boyle Heights
I'm like come on come on I got you
let's roll let's do this [ __ ] like I see
it as a whole movement you know like but
yeah for sure [ __ ] Dario and Fabian
man for sure I thought what you started
with those guys - I think everything he
learned he shared with me so really easy
easily able to grow and really transform
cuz even when he met me I wasn't like ah
no child or at but I was like on like I
guess hardcore hip-hop or it's like no
way versus comfortable and do it
you know and since since then just
building off that yeah what about um I
miss Kyle you're the second video you I
saw yours do what I say all that she's
good it was very good it was good man
the beats and everything and also the
video quality that's what I noticed this
guy oh good actually
it was every homie it was shot really
good yeah see him but he's mighty Mudds
right here mud mighty muds over there so
he's a guy go kato he's undercover it's
keeping a low-key low profile so you got
you also battle every battle fools yet i
used to do like rap battles and downtown
a few years what we're at Art Walk I
don't write on oh yeah I actually got
stabbed at Art Walk not on some battle
rap [ __ ] son just on some regular beef
[ __ ] they stabbed me with a paintbrush
an artist he was pissed off and what was
he pissed off no no just a [ __ ] you know
I tell you the name will find them find
us I do love our walk though is crazy
like I have a crazy history with our
walk by used to battle down there Alex
theater a late period the Honan okay
Alex theater ready to battle they're
right outside
no no it was like on spring and like fit
it was just some like some ship some
foods just put together like it wasn't
any like type of big like leaguer or any
wow org and I [ __ ] it literally I seem
to add in Ali weekly I went down in
downtown and just oh that's cool about
it that's how I started my stand-up
comedy man I won't see rad looking for
50 comedians right now now just show up
hopefully with me or I'm open mic I will
go over there man that's why I started
my eye man I don't know how to start
stand-up comedy so I just went to Ali
weekly straight up and where'd you go
like the last pages in the back yeah but
that's the last place the last page of
massage parlors oh yeah you don't get
the gig you go to the last page you're
like well I'm glad that I'm along the
I met people that you know lead that I
mean we later you know you meet people
they help you but then you all grow them
then you have to get move on to the next
person because they're full of it over
here green chairs could I pass them you
know that's a real [ __ ] man sorry man
I'm sorry that you taught me how to use
their sword but she only used one sword
I'm over here [ __ ] with two swords
I'm making my own sores now [ __ ] you
know her sorry man that you know that
I'm you didn't changing the times you
know that but um I've had a lot of
people help me man like I have people
like um they're just lately it led me to
okay man you're really the funniest here
go to the next room so I would always go
to places where there were new comedians
you know I stay in one place I'm like
the funniest but too many open to many
new people you know I mean just like
everybody where I was going was new
every week was somebody new you know so
I had to move my ass to some places
where everybody been doing it for a long
time so I could suck for a while
let me tell myself for a long last time
who sure went back to the other room
well sign autographs but it happens
right yeah it's just sad but it is you
you you but you were right
mother-father don't even call me now
they were Phillippi bad these are bad
eating steak now look at him all badass
see it for real is bad especially for
you guys cuz you guys don't come from
[ __ ] middle-class neighborhoods you
have to come for no [ __ ] white picket
fence unless you live in White Fence
anyway so but um they think like some
people hate man like you could be
drinking a [ __ ] ginger ale for the
first time ginger ale just a flavor soda
and you post miss Carlito here drinking
ginger chips sipping a ginger ale in the
studio [ __ ] this fool right here
drinking champagne champagne you back
[ __ ] that Canada Dry we're sipping
champagne that's what I feel like we're
getting now
this who thinks he's all bad phase I
told him that sunlight we're gonna hit
that you think you're all bad now yeah
we got the big place when we pay dues
and a lot of foods are feeling like that
real salty like a man you got there
because you got the deserve it bro
nobody Henry got nothing that should
have been me yeah plus you guys have to
win a cocktail or something right to be
on it
you know what thankfully we didn't have
to do none type of [ __ ] like that just
put us on check it out
he just DM dust like that's what he said
first always like y'all want to do a big
show we say there's going to be a big
show so we're like MERS of course we
want to do a big show and like in the
next day or two and do campaign for it
who's will do straight-up competitions
campaigns get all their their followers
and their people in order which is dope
I've seen it happen for years and years
like an underground paid dues is like
that [ __ ] if you get it selected for it
or you campaign for it then all you the
[ __ ] now merged merge gave you that cred
so for us it was kind of like we weren't
expecting it but [ __ ] it's just been a
it's been a crib in a trip man it's been
a blessing no man it's sad that how the
dome you the energy is right now because
you know these guys they say they got
picked by MERS right but I'm pretty sure
- people out there you know with parents
they have a lot of money Amer's here's
ten G's just put my son in a [ __ ]
show no questions asked I am below he
got some merch already ready for you got
a thousand CDs here's 10 G's
to look the other way put them up right
after McCauley mad max so they want to
do war before them I want them to shine
happen I'm pretty sure that [ __ ]
happens because I don't know what this
festival I don't I think Murray's can't
be tainted he's good everyone on that
line about somebody like that [ __ ]
happens all the time man
cuz dude I'm hosting this bigger show
right it's called the Tropic Kalia
festival and a little teasing North is
head like oh I saw that I spent in wood
all that [ __ ] right but I been getting
hit up by a lot of bands that you know a
man I have a band you know will do
whatever it takes to get on the show man
even if we have to pay you and I'm like
[ __ ] it I'm gonna say man that's [ __ ]
up that you have to pay to get on shows
but there they pick me I'm not doing the
lineup but I'll gladly put you waterfall
in my show if you have to pay to get on
but that happened I pay to play right
now in the underground it's notorious
there's food zoo who throw shows [ __ ]
big showcases they call them they tell
artists young artists who are dumb yo
you could get on pay me 200 bucks Sal
these 20 tickets make your money back if
you can sell them and I'm gonna give you
10 minutes 15 minutes and it's a it's a
rout call pay to play and fools get got
on that all the time especially young
and up-and-comers I mean it's it's
pretty bad man that works in comedy -
[ __ ] yeah yeah that works in comedy - it
only like young comedians fall for that
but they may grow out of it you know and
it's not going nowhere bro I keep
starting [ __ ] ticket CDs yeah I have
to go before him I have to go up before
the hosts
well can't say you guys slept your way
to the top good you got not that
attractive I wasn't working out for you
man cause like we've had we've had our
first guest are for
here with who baby bashing kid frost
yeah at the same time and we were lucky
to get them and then after that we had
that gay rapper deadly total gay rapper
bro
he does like he's like you know that is
right yeah he's part of the gay hip-hop
scene and in a heart
hardcore cholo homo cholo homo no I call
that food super talk or a homo cholo
okay cuz deadly is deadly better [ __ ]
watch out and we had to mix three weeks
ago he got a shout-out reverie that's
what I saw every - she was on pace due
to gender you get like how many years
ago right like potty wine or maybe five
years ago or so murder you're excited
was this [ __ ] big bad that is bro I'm
gonna do a show whether the Club Nokia I
get the goose box to get a body man cuz
you know you could do the Hollywood you
could do the improper now man down I
live where it's at [ __ ] yeah yeah
because you made it man you know man you
[ __ ] pass by even later on your
return you pass by performing that [ __ ]
yeah and then we ask you to April
they're guest list
[ __ ] yeah it's called it's at
Ticketmaster it was a guest there for
East I love you typically show up you
ask know the guest slip a guest list for
the daily death show bro free tour show
up there was a guest list for the self
how graphic show you didn't [ __ ] show
up [ __ ]
and I know you see big names attached to
my name you want to go see lucky we're
not there yet like we're not big so when
people hit or someone like you know
ain't got no juice right now maybe in a
couple years we could get you on the
guest list but where people hitting us
that like he's supposed to be the big
homie what ya got a lot of groupies
just mail groupie showing up dogs I got
that weed for you back page we used to
have residents yet and we brought some
homies out from the IE and then towards
like the end of their set one of their
fans that came out I guess she was just
having a good time
she just woo flashes her shirt like
never happens out of hip-hop's I don't
know that happens at comedy shows if you
get many girls that flash you titties
but another time bro ha I'm like stop it
or no well they're nice one at least the
one I get flat they're not good was his
old lady flash me bro oh you like
somebody it like somebody got two long
socks and put a bowling ball shoot about
to kill Goliath with those and then I
should've Buster give somebody a cold
red were so fool max mascot right here
pay dues to her when you were growing up
man you grew up in did you see all that
crazy [ __ ] you were like bought five
doing other shootouts all that [ __ ] yeah
I was just young enough to see it and
not have to participate or be in that
that crossroad and [ __ ] cuz I would see
some of my older homies are some of my
older cousins who were just born in the
lifestyle who were just you they were at
that age and boom they just sort of gang
banging crazy got crazy 1981 bro
were you born in 94 I've run a t-888
round three around that time I'm walking
home and [ __ ] yeah just crazy I grew up
in the project my grandma I lived there
you
so I stood in the same house right there
no right there where you live at right
there we know you live right there with
it where you grew up at there's that
wall with your mom lives and then
there's a other wall I don't know who
used to live there but across the street
from you guys was Koch at this right
John Wayne yeah yeah John Wayne and
Rubin wafu right through that alley
these two be a hood called I don't know
they were a hood hood they're more like
a team get her boys a bunch of ghetto
boys they were hanging out right there
and and these fools to always [ __ ] with
me kind of right like we're playing
baseball the same am gonna get a little
hit and I give him the bat and then
[ __ ] I hit the ball real far and then
there's no more ball Butchie come on
Punk take off with a bat - oh [ __ ]
somebody uh you can't play baseball no
more so man these fool this fool from
Harlem back children high school and
rose about that I knew from up there
right hit his name I like I forgot his
last name to open it his first name was
last name was Sam moody oh all right and
F we have pimple in his face but they
were like he was like it were James
almost you know I mean and he was boss
bro Oh dog like he to walk with her to
get a big chest in junior high so he was
a bigger chest in high school and he'll
it was and that was and then um that he
was so another food that I known him
wrong Raul he's most a lot of weed and
he was there was another fool know he
was there was Robert and another guy and
those ghetto boys right so this will
show up on cool he wearing his dumb
Indian leather moccasins
you know stoners rrz shirt ba you know
and well he goes your man has any weed
so then the food from ghetto boys are
all loaded and in that food so what so
then their food that I knew Robert he
started fighting one of the guy from
ghetto boys and man they're both dude I
just I just heard this dog and then some
food fell on the ground then I heard
another one the other fool found a
ground
he knocked out three fools one with a
cheap shot one with a regular sock and
the other one got sucked by two people
at the same time but they both got
knocked until that knocked out and then
when I forgot knocked out I was like far
all that left to do is pee on these guys
I mean that's all I left to do was to
pee on these guys and they got knocked
out dog like I'll bro like sleepy bro
Sleeping Beauty knocked out and I was
like [ __ ] man justice was finally served
in this neighborhood the ghetto boys
fell asleep finally
hell yeah bro last last year halloween
fell over the weekend get a boy with
trick-or-treating bro they got cold cold
bro but that dude was big bro he was
[ __ ] Big Dawg man and be into this
day if my friends are listening to the
podcast
there are a grimmer yet oh [ __ ] man if
they would do that they were more pissed
off they wouldn't help them bro when
they got knocked out we were jumping
over them a dope ring finger the witches
damn the witches day the which is it
Roza best naka ever see clean clean dog
clean badges three over bro and then he
kicked him with a moccasins bro what's
your party photobooth voice he was a
thief of crazy [ __ ] house [ __ ] like that
was like a common theme you had a like
grow thick [ __ ] skin at a young age I
realized that like [ __ ] [ __ ] goes down
in the projects he's a funny man over
there like let's just that's just people
who are not in no gang man fighting
right she's fooling not really no gangs
they're just regular Joe's you know you
know who has a bigger dick and they
started fighting but the homies on the
other hand
man I've seen fools get out of line and
get bitch-slapped for everybody dog but
what are you doing - hold your faith and
shut up
I never been bitch-slap I've been
slapped by my bad guy but by women down
fool I remember the food guy what's up
man what's up blood you chicken you
taking the other side you take it aside
to get to homie and bam broth slap in
the face
check him real quick checking on bro and
it took his PCP money yeah my only lot
of drive-by a lot of not even drive-by
shooting when you grew up marriages walk
by shootings who used to walk huh yeah
it was it was a trip growing up growing
up down there man but it was also like
there's a lot of people where it's funny
my uncle always used to say he missed
the project might be odo fees cuz he
said those like you know like the
community the family that you grow there
because everyone lives so close yeah
everyone shares that common struggle
where people just seem more connected
there it's funny because when they move
everyone out they move everyone out they
tore down the projects and forth and
then they rebuilt him and then after
that everything was just a lot
differently the favor more village now
it's a gated community
the windows are gated the back doors
really his uncle dofus when I first
started doing stand-up comedy like maybe
like the fifth time going up on stage I
invited that fool you know your uncle
went to my show at the Acapulco
restaurant in Hollywood it don't exist
no more but it was on Brea and Sunset
and they had a comedy contest so I
invited everybody from the project John
Wayne [ __ ] Chino with Lupino a little
Asian kid his [ __ ] brother duck
John and Dole fees and then I [ __ ]
killed at that show but all the homies
voted armed they were all clapping for
me and I won I want a $50 growing up how
many contests and I remember your uncle
was sitting in a back of the bar with
John Wayne
we caught the food John Wayne cuz
they're big ass cheeks he was sitting
with John Wayne and they were just
drinking
bro like you know it would to me it felt
good to see like people from my
neighborhood outside of the neighborhood
having a good time
so therefore was drinking he was
drinking beer bro and I remember many
people mentioning auto-feeding John went
over there drinking drinking beer and
eating like socialites he was like that
yeah well his uncle just dressed good
look at cholo everybody respected him I
remember they used to be this [ __ ]
crazy crackhead that was no the only
customer but [ __ ] glasses nice to be
my customer 212 broken glasses I forgot
and now four had a good job crasher or
Raider or something that he was a
regular Joe huh yeah a regular job I
mean functioning like crackin regular
Joe he live in the projects he would
just show up like a normal man and you
could tell this guy had a family
somewhere out that we don't know about
but see that was a drugs take your bro
in a normal day that I go that guy would
have never ever drove him even if you
would invite him to a birthday party he
woulda never took his family there but
the drugs you know when you're hooked
and you're [ __ ] gone bro you go to
hell bro that was just for him a little
you go to a Klan meeting to bike rack
that's all if the only ones that have it
you're gonna go get it honey how did you
get oh boy not getting jumped into a
gang or getting [ __ ] hooked on heroin
or PCP [ __ ] Wow
for me not joining the game was easy my
dad would have [ __ ] me up and then I
had my uncle doe fees and other people
like that where I didn't have to worry
about that and I was always just like
kind of like after school program
basketball whatever anything that I
could do that wasn't just [ __ ] around
on the block then it was just like
supported
after-school programs the basketball to
football to baseball anything that took
away from not doing and we we do a
little program on Fridays from 3:00 to
6:00 every every Friday in Boyle Heights
right in right in front of our studios
right on 1st Street in between Cummings
and state right by the mortuary on
Fridays we do 3 to 6 before they do the
the services at the mortuary we do a hip
hop thing right there and it's for the
same reason just to show kids like we're
doing it roll up get out the streets for
a few hours come and trip out see people
scratchy and see people flowing be
exposed to stuff that [ __ ] I wasn't
exposed to growing up on a hip hop tip
you know what I mean and we got duck on
that Rosa good taco man yeah bro I don't
know your dad because I should see him
at the project's when you were dating
your mom before you were born and um he
was and he was hard to sports darts go
to the boy or boy in arrow parties if
they have one he still plays darts
yeah he's the play starts today he's
here to play softball bro like hardcore
like [ __ ] the ball look I don't like a
dolly but below lay no shorts [ __ ] their
ball look I never meant I got fired
cuz I didn't get fired I they were to
change my schedule and they're not being
a dick
but he came in to his father came in to
be the supervisor after already was
there so when I saw him I know who you
are because you're um Sylvia's husband
and weirdo for and Rudy and Louie Jackie
oh yeah yeah yeah but you never you
never used to see me and well long story
short dog every time you slick right I
don't know what kind of meeting him and
I we're gonna have so far buddy a tape
recorder brother I put it right there a
tape recorder right and I push play it
looks like I was crazy
will you hold me what are you do we eat
it I know my rights
he goes he could pull out that card let
me go come on man all right Melwood we
were talking bar a look the company's
policy you know that girl was Oh phoo
what's up Paul Rodriguez was so fool we
were here in the park and we're just
talking about you and Mike Gomez doing a
play if we are so numerous if we you can
throw rock in either direction that hit
Susan the head disappeared if the number
one song around the world is deceived oh
we got our own Grammys come on
television
everybody is that a development he'll
this year it hasn't gone on to pilot
they just went on there's like 12 new
african-american shows now I'm not down
in african-americans I'm simply saying
that the squeaky wheel gets the grease
let us complain I forget Americans
complain that the Oscars are to what
yeah any more any less but you know they
don't have no Latinos in a
decision-making process that can
greenlight projects so consequently they
go black they don't go brown we need to
have them change their mind there should
be room enough in the 24 hours of
television please I know a good my were
one of those deals that didn't get
picked up last year
mine was a pilot bidding his shot last
year and yours with one fluffy they
rejected Angela Johnson's too
Angela that's what I'm saying it's 12 0
12 new african-american shows zero
Latinos if it was 12 3 we'd say we're in
the game if it was 12 2 would say we're
in the game we're not winning but we're
in the game if it was 12 1 when they
were in the game but we're in the game
to pick up the phone to get on the
internet to come and see what I'm
talking about am I just crazy I know
that but the [ __ ] independent is an
indictment it's a courtroom it just puts
them lets them know that there's
blackish but there should be brownish
with the largest ethnic minority are we
not as talented we can act we're not
funny
well the problem is the person making
the decisions doesn't think we're funny
because they don't know us they don't
live around us they don't never see more
Latinos of what they consider to their
height you know we're nanny and your
babies with mowing your lawn it's what I
call the American loves the taco they
just have problems epochal we're not
going away and that the president Trump
pardoning this is far right Arpaio is
only embolden him those people let them
know that it's all right to violate our
civil rights because the president well
he doesn't know right he was guilty he
should have gone to jail he should have
paid for that and if you don't believe
me any Latino is dragging down the
streets of Phoenix by the way we're
gonna be in Phoenix on the 30th of
September at the Comerica arena baby
anyone that gets there gets pulled over
you got to prove you're a citizen ass
violation of the rights that's pro
finally it won't care how many times
they pardon wrong is wrong and right is
right we're gonna continue to be a thorn
on their side Yemen so this place the
word is play play now so everybody could
know the Los Angeles theater it's the
first time I wrote a play it's I can't
even spell but somehow I got it on we've
been raising money from donors the
thickest I've kept them in low so people
have no excuse it's 15 bucks
come on popcorn cost that much at movies
50 bucks for students $25 for general
admission
please come supportive I can only afford
7 days it runs from the seventh to the
17th of September to choose
nice and if you just sleeping on my
couch here and we're all making
sacrifices but we feel this is important
enough is enough is enough how can it be
that all of us say well you know what
Filipa deserves to be on the air more
power to you I know the brother will
call me let me do it guess what you know
but not you not me not each night Angela
Justin that you know you're gonna pee on
us don't tell me it's raining are you
saying that they couldn't first of all
in my opinion we had cheats my son and
myself we they gave us a development
right and they are saying their own
writers their own writers white writers
who wrote a pilot what they wrote they
you just the troublemaker hard work if
you don't complain they run they
rejected [ __ ] that they wrote not that I
wrote so they rejected themselves and
Marlon an NBC well god bless Martin hope
it goes and the girls on Showtime in the
mayor and ABC and all this stuff where
are we the census said we are far more
numerous we're the number one ethnic
minority across America
seventy billion plus strong that they
know of right for some of the cream of
the crop if they can find better people
to to give deals to other than you you
know but there should be room for more
than just the Jennifer Lopez I know man
and they they expect you to be happy
with one show one
a man it won't be a we're gonna have a
love we have to we have to have enough
Latino shows on TV so we cut our saying
you know that one sucks chance we can we
gotta fight for more we can just sit
back and be passive we gotta take a page
from our african-american brothers and
sisters and become active tweet do
something seek my show see the play
support Latinos so we're gonna get to
where we're going which is to eventually
have the same presence that our music
has around the world
yeah lets-a-go romeo sample boy solo
dumb yankee stadium twice don't know why
those there are two billion views there
you go this [ __ ] for us not that
latino [ __ ] support Latinos to stop this
I'm CUBAN are Mexican and Cuba and
Puerto Rican I'm have this we should
just support each other you know because
one day if we don't support each other
they won't be there to support us
mr. krauser this is change this attitude
thing people see each other as brothers
and sisters
speaking the same language with a
different twist that's all it is
yeah man I'm doing good bro right here
I'm right here interviewing these two
young rappers from Boyle Heights we have
miss Kyle right here we have Mad Max
right here they're a big big party your
fans they love born in East LA we're
gonna come out and support the play
we're gonna come out and support the IC
by IB IC party hey bro drink twenty nine
shots of tequila rip two decks of back
red cards and win 17 GS loud protests
make a joyful noise let them know we're
here September 7 to 17 turn about that
time Energy's almost through their plane
Andy Garcia keep it steady
I'll tell you when to go down you just
we're guys mr. almost this is a very
difficult landing because between these
two rocky points and it's like a short
Canales less than a mile wide before us
there's this there's this opening and
it's right between these two giant rocks
and the plane goes right in the middle
we land
fish I choose the ground like the Pope
life and it was I said and that's what
he does Star Trek working on the wings
watching you and I said this boy has
learned his lesson and now he's ready to
teach us oh yeah give us some pause I
knew that was gonna happen
I took you with me always I never told
you hey you know don't be funny I never
gave you those restrictions I just want
you to do your thing and then you have
made me proud
that's I love you man thank you oh yeah
I'm not like that no more remember well
jump on Jesus bro hopefully your
activism spark some some movement in
this culture leading us to
I'll do it it's all good if it works
well I'll get a job if it doesn't then
I'll be blackballed but he'll what can
they do to me I'm not working now okay
let's not try to learn land the plane
will just take off yeah man were so fool
what's the play again
funny we were talking about Mike Gomez
right now and I was telling everybody
who's a who's my Gomez come on bro you
know my Gomez he Pawnee has the most
recognizable row on the big lebowski he
was a cop and I'm telling everybody when
I first saw him at the Latino show and
nobody knew he was out of the first guy
walk up to him and hug him and tell him
bro you killed it and a Big Lebowski
then I had 20 other people walk up to
him and tell him the same thing
we were like he was like we were in he
were starstruck actually tormented
Vietnam veteran play and it's he's just
a fine actor man yeah you also DC care
man don't forget DC cab you are there
party with Marion Barry and and [ __ ]
Gary Busey
this time I pretty in do go to Reverend
school thank you Paul we got miss
Carlito here and Mad Max we're gonna be
paid September 16 where else can I find
you on your social media they could find
us the easiest way is at each OTR
network that's the east of the river
network that is pretty much the umbrella
that we host all you find us you find
other artists you find entrepreneurs you
find DJs you find comedians you know
engineers whatever we just try to stay
connected on the east side and just help
each other out so
Mad Max we're gonna find you your music
is on Spotify SoundCloud yes - Viva
mezcal you can find it on all of that
Spotify Pandora iTunes are all that good
stuff man you smoke a lot of weed huh
that video got weed cherry my blunt
going to smoking weed the whole time
yeah yeah
that was a good [ __ ] song too good
song yeah man
oh man I wish you guys all the best yet
more than welcome to come back anytime I
know I don't just say that all the time
and much success to the project homey
right here all the way hell yeah man hey
Thank You Felipe [ __ ] been following
you for a minute
for show the hood and Boyle Heights sees
you and everyone loves you do so well so
full shut up - Paul Rodriguez give Nepal
hey it's Paul Rodriguez check out my
play the pitch September 7 through 13
early theater foo little fool
yeah quick photo